Mariela is with us in Phoenix Arizona hi
Mari el how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up well we
were debt-free and then my husband he
decided to use a personal credit card to
pay for liability insurance for a small
business that we had about four months
later we had to shut down the business
and now we're stuck with this $8,000
credit card statement that we can't pay
at this point he's associated because
the creditors are coming after him and
he's negotiated 150 at zero APR until as
the balance is paid off but we've been
going through a hardship for the last
couple years and we can repeat that now
he's having he's receiving letter saying
that they're pursuing legal action and
I'm just wondering if there's any any
way we can settle at this point or for
beyond the point of return we're never
beyond the point of return $8,000 makes
the whole thing go away well why are you
still struggling years after closing the
business my husband was having a hard
time finding employment or a single
family income right now and have two
small children and I see home with them
what does he do he's a project manager a
project manager for a construction
company okay well I think there's a
construction boom in Phoenix he can't
find work well he's working now he he
was keeping more things for about six
months and what does he make 45 thousand
a year okay and he works 40 hours yes
he's salary so whatever it's more like
60 hours but but he's putting in 60
hours in making forty five grand right
and that's all a project manager makes
in construction business in Phoenix
Yeah right now hold it he uh he is 15
what kind of business closed it was a
plumbing business it was a family
business a plumbing business so he's a
plumber not trade right okay
so on the weekends could he do handyman
work and make some extra money
yeah we've trade that route
right now he's got a chance for with a
project with his mom's house but he's
been doing as a favor for the family but
yeah that's nice but you're getting sued
on a credit card right happening are
they gonna sue us well it's kind of
stupid
I'm working on my mom's house so I can't
go make money to pay my bill that I owe
so I'm gonna get sued hmm that's kind of
bad choices
what kinda really yes all right so tell
mom her projects got to wait because
he's got to go make some money okay so
we can pay this bill because here's the
thing the $8,000 credit card debt has
not been paid on and how long we're
behind about two or three months now
okay and how old is the debt coming up
on two years okay so they'll take
probably to $3,000 if you offered it to
them lump sum as a settlement in full
you get that in writing from them before
you give them any money and then you
work it through that way but you got to
have the two or three thousand dollars
to make the offer so we have that in a
savings account but that's that'll clean
us out so she'll make the offer okay how
much is in savings about 3 grand 3 grand
okay you can offer him - you don't get
below one and then he needs to work
three extra jobs okay and quit doing
favors for his mother he's broke until
you get this mess cleaned up we try to
settle with them in the past and they
keep telling us that's not an option
because we've already offered you this
your APR
all everything is an option okay they
got no money here's what you get you get
nothing I got nothing
sue me good luck with that or you can
take $2,000 or I'll try to save up a
little bit more but right now I'm not
giving you nothing you get nothing or
you get $2,000 if you want to take
$2,000 I'll give it to you today but
it's settlement in full in writing from
you or I'm not sending you any money oh
we won't do that
okay good call me back when you feel
better and hang up okay
and then save up some more money and
then call them back and offer them three
thousand dollars
they'll take three believe me if your
right to work at it I mean they don't
just like oh thank you for calling we're
so happy to talk to you know their butts
because they're collectors it's what
they do and they're gonna argue and act
like they're gonna come take your
firstborn from you and they're nasty
human beings they're not fun to talk to
so you just got a fight and argue push
through it but do not give them any
money unless you have the settlement in
writing and you have the cash to give
them that settlement amount don't agree
to any more payments ever with these
people okay and get your husband's butt
in gear on making some money so you got
a little more money to give them and get
them out of your life yeah ventually
they're gonna get around to suing you
but no it's not too late and you can
always call them and say you know you
don't have to sue me I'll give you
$2,000 right now the settlement will
take two thousand on the account no you
misunderstood your parents cousins or
something I said two thousand settles
the account and you just have to argue
with them because they're not bright
people if they were bright people they'd
have a better job right okay well that's
helpful thank you very much get after it
kiddo
I sure well let me tell you what's
happening okay I'm standing back looking
at this whole thing from a distance you
guys have been passive it's time for you
guys to be active okay you've let this
happen to you now it's time for you and
him to happen to it and that will fix
this problem but you keep wandering off
and going on he's just having our times
and now you don't have to get with it
get with it crank it up crank it up hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]